we have dr. Jeanne Sinquefield with us
famously five years ago spearheading the
chess merit badge now the namesake of
this tournament maybe means and also the
author of a new book and actually we
have a lot of listeners as who viewers
that is who say that our analysis is too
advanced for us foolish because they're
just getting into the game maybe this is
all about this from a mainstream and
what I find is what really the problem
often is that they don't allow jabrai
notation yet so they actually can't just
understand the language and this book is
about that and Maurice's wit dr. Jeanne
to talk about that and lots of other
projects we're with dr. Jeanne Singh
field formerly known as Miss Jean pile
of rocks
she told us herself the Scottish meaning
of the word Karen's which I had never
heard before myself but you told us at
the opening ceremony welcome to the Shea
could be for a hundred feet high right
big pile oh well thank you so much tell
us about the inception of this
tournament of course we know that
there's a lot of tournaments for guys
that that get done but to get a elite
tournament for women must have been
something special finally for you to see
yeah it's there's been a lot of people
were saying when are we gonna have a
really top rated women's tournament I
mean from just players in the club and
people that we've met you know around
the world and and so the staff kept
saying let's we let's do it and then
they should say that should be named
after me so I said okay they do all the
work I get all the credit I think that's
wonderful well I mean you guys have done
so much here already incredible chess
taking place all the time what have you
been what have you felt from the young
ladies you've met here so far glue that
you had dinner with them and got a
chance to meet some of them they're you
know it's very happy to be here because
there's not a lot of let's say well paid
tournaments for women that highlight the
women so they were very excited actually
most of them have never even been to st.
Louis some of them never been to the US
so it's funnest
and we've had I was talking to a young
girl today I think she's in middle
school highest rating was like 1500 and
she drove up from Texas because an
astute and ski who lives in Germany was
her coach there you go
have you gotten a chance to meet really
get a chance to talk to any of the
players yeah well yeah we had dinner
I've talked to a variety of them and and
it's it's like they're really enjoying
coming and me you know playing with
these great players and you have great
commentators and I'm it's amazing number
of grandmasters female grandmasters for
those who aren't you know into chess you
have to understand how difficult that is
to get that title how many people we
could certainly have a lot more female
grandmasters as well but we have seven
of them here playing in this competition
right now you also are an author I know
you always try to pick my brain for ID
for how to better improve the things
that you're doing but you did come out
with this new book read learn to read
and write chess tell us why you follow
there was a need for this well I
couldn't read and write chess and I
would it was looking in the material and
I didn't like what was there and
and I realized that it's like learning
any foreign language like learning math
or learning computer languages or even a
foreign language there's certain things
that you have to break it apart to learn
it and what was out there just wasn't if
I wanted to have a mother teach their
kid how to read and write home they
don't know how to read and write it's
never going to happen
the kids not going to learn so we we
broke it up so the there's pages on
teaching about the letters and there's
pages teaching them about the board and
then about the structure of the moves
the order of the moves I think a couple
of grandmasters said they learned
something from from that well it's very
important to have someone who is not a
chess player made that bridge between
the non
player and the reading and writing part
I'm in a for hire I'm a professional
chess player that's that's what I really
meant I knew you you know the moves you
also did what an amazing initiative with
the Boy Scouts as Jennifer mentioned as
well
and now the Girl Scouts have come in
Girl Scouts okay
it's the Boy Scouts of America now have
troops there's just four girls but we
don't call them
we call them Scouts BSA okay I stand
corrected
just because we already have Girl Scouts
in America we had 12 girls who came and
we're as far as we know the first girls
in America are in the chest merit badge
here in Missouri right where we had the
launch for the chess merit badge five
years ago where two hundred thousand
boys have earned the badge and we see
some great footage here of some young
ladies and there's Jennifer talking to
them as well and it must really warm
your heart because your numbers are so
ridiculous I mean how many new people
have you brought to chess and with a
chess merit badge is not something
that's easy to attain you actually have
to know your stuff yeah what are yours
now at 200,000 that's more than the
membership in the US Jess Federation and
they have to teach to others how to play
chess Wow so that's 600,000 is it to
others outside of the outside of their
troop no it could be people in the truth
go outside the truth so it's it's what
you're doing is and unlike like clubs
like the big cities have clubs the small
towns are struggling to have clubs but
troops are located in tiny towns across
America so we're getting Scouts to learn
to play chess everywhere and they're
playing at summer camps and they're
doing Eagle projects building chess
parks so you're building the base in a
way like has never been done probably in
the history of u.s. chess oh that's the
idea is to find and
chess players we'll think about it if
you're gonna be a professional chess
player you have to have an audience as
well and the audience has to be able to
read and write chess and know how to
play and love the game and you want to
have and most people aren't gonna become
professional chess players like most
kids who play Little League don't even
get into high school ball doesn't mean
you don't love the sport right
absolutely
well finally at the opening ceremony
there's a little trash talking going on
between you and Rex they're saying
something about Karen's cup is gonna be
even better than the Sinquefield Cup
about you guys are very competitive with
each other you know he was he's been
doing all of this stuff up here okay you
know the best players in the world and
whatever I'm just trying to you know
compete so I get more down here kids and
stuff and the women can kick ass too
that's all I'm talking about we will
leave it right there no better words
have been said thank you so much for
everything you do for chest